got a good birthday coming up uh later
it's the big Creo the big for you
I'm 30 years yeah yeah I know you always
talk about yourself my 20s were hard
really yeah so I was lonely I didn't
have a band
I was lonely so much fun here I love my
band it's hard like when you're in the
spot like that to like you know just
communicate what that's like so I was
yeah 20s were hard but 30s were cool
you're gonna love it my 20s are fun I
had a great time
um whatever Nile
I was no I was having a great time in my
20s I really enjoyed it um do you freak
out about age are you freaking out about
it no I'm one of those people I couldn't
care less honestly I like everybody
talks about the 30s being the new 20s so
yeah I'm up for
um
feel older my hangovers are worse harder
very long your knees as well you know
what I mean the knees I know soccer is
hard on you yeah it is
um but no I'm looking forward to it I
um my best friend since I was like three
years old his parents and my parents
were in the same class at school we were
in the same class at school his name is
Molly and um I'm sorry Molly from
mullinger
Holland like the street here
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah and we're he's like five weeks six
weeks older than me okay and we're gonna
do a joint 30th because I hate 30th
used to be over here after 13 years no
13. 13. after 13 years I still think
it's funny
um no so what are y'all gonna you're
gonna be do a big joint thing yeah I
don't like
the last time I celebrated the birthday
was 21 went to Vegas did the whole the
whole deal that was yeah that was big
and then I haven't celebrated really
since I'm not really a birthday guy but
30 of them definitely gonna do really
the 30th one yeah um so Kelly please I'm
gonna keep doing it awesome I love it so
wait why don't you don't like so you
like just being low-key I don't know I
just like I'd go for a few drinks with a
few mates or yeah make sure that there's
no okay so I do it yeah I don't like
surprises I hate surprises I hate them
yeah um and I also don't like the happy
birthday to have to be like I love that
yeah yeah yeah so don't do that if
you're gonna surprise me I did hear that
you don't like when people sing Happy
Birthday to you so I'm totally gonna get
Shelton to do that for me on video to
send it oh I don't mind it like if it's
been sent to me or whatever but if you
know when you're in a room
four rooms looking at you and it's like
a 40 second
Spiel compliment thing yeah don't
doesn't that happen like every time you
end a song on like the stage
I guess so yeah it's a different thing
don't you hate when people just sit
there and adore you but you can't just
like you can't stop it's not like you
can clap along yeah it's not like you
sing along to your own birthdays um yeah
I know you yeah I would
um and yeah it's never been never been a
fan of the birthday thing but uh okay
duly noted yeah
well I wanted to ask you about a lyric
from Heaven um and this is so great
y'all it goes let's not get complicated
let's just enjoy the view it's hard to
be a human so much to put an answer to
but that's just what we do what inspired
that lyric I love that yeah so good I
guess that heaven kind of for me came
from like
just from previous generations Society
kind of tells us you need to do this at
this age you need to do that at that age
all these Milestones whether it be
marriage kids whatever it may be have a
career at this age do not at that age
and I was just like I've always been one
of those like I know for the for lack of
a better Phrase live in the moment kind
of person and just kind of like
whatever's in front of you just do it
and then deal with it yeah as you go so
I kind of always had that I was just
saying it to the guys when when I
started singing God only knows where
this could go I was thinking that's just
a life thought and I think that's
exciting to not know yeah like God only
knows where this could go I think that's
cool the opportunity of what that could
be is cool yeah I like I like the I
don't like surprises generally if
someone's gonna come in and surprise me
but I do like surprises in life and
things popping up for good or for bad to
be honest like if it pops up you deal
with it and if it's good you deal with
it and yeah just hopefully you learn
another way yeah either way yeah that's
the idea I guess such a great song I
mean the Melody's cool the lyrics are
awesome it's just I love how the
Melodies there's so many there's like a
few different like just major hooks
going on I love that I want to do
another lyric though um in your first
solo which I love and it reminds me of
like I feel like you could have like
grown up in Nashville because this is
such a singer-songwriter song it's
called This Town everybody knows that
um
you know because the whole world was
watching I'd still dance with you that's
always Drive highways and buy ways to be
there with you over and over the only
truth everything comes back to you
like is there do you have to have a
certain Muse or can you just be inspired
at the idea
like when that feels personal but you
might be one of those people that can
write about that want that to be mine I
have no issue writing about anything I'm
I'm one of those people I do try and
keep like have that as a single thought
and then build a storyline around it
that's what tend to do like this song
was basically about my hometown and kind
of everything that I feel about it now
that I've spent time traveling the world
away from it yeah you know it's like
you're like I when you're there you're
like I hate this place oh I gotta get
out I hate your mom yeah and then you're
like oh yeah I want to go home now yeah
and I think the older I've gotten the
more of wanted to go back
um but yeah it just it's that's what
I've always like when I write
when I think of my hometown it straight
away brings up finger picking and yeah
Nashville songwriting and folky kind of
stuff and that's what I naturally do
when I pick up a Guitar I naturally just
like finger pick and yeah and all that
kind of good stuff that's what it's so
natural to me like even our
conversations with you know Blake and
James like backstage like I feel like
you are that you are just like that
writing Community like which is so cool
because you love storytelling I love a
story yeah me too
[Music]
[Applause]